hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by the patron saint of
first we feast Guy Fieri he owns nine
restaurants has three hit TV shows and
six best-selling cookbooks and speaking
of you can pick up his latest Guy Fieri
family food available now guy welcome to
the show
it's quite an intro you got fee Eddie
right Danny of the Lord I don't know
time again if they get it wrong every
time you knocked it out of the park I'll
Pat myself on the back of that how are
you with hot food I'm not an extreme hot
guy but I do like good spice and I think
that we don't have enough spice in our
food I mean I know a couple of these
down here on the end just turn to the
point where you're solving taste buds
yeah but I do appreciate that you know
it's out there and people have it but
this is this is my realm right in here
probably up to this ghost pepper
blueberry drink it up
[Music]
oh yeah sriracha is one of my favorite
looks I'm bad wing diners drive-ins and
dives that's been going strong for 22
seasons so I think that it's only fair
for the Triple D fans that I hit you
with a quick rapid-fire on wing one
what's one thing that all successful
restaurant owners have in common they
serve food really good food if you're
gonna be in the business you got to love
what you're doing otherwise you're gonna
you're never gonna get the return on
investment not for time and energy if
you could have any co-hosts living or
dead to sit shotgun with you and the
Camaro who would it be
Rodney Dangerfield I think Rodney
Dangerfield is one of my favorite
comedians in the whole world
funny guy quick guy quick-witted guy you
know a lot of what goes on very similar
to what I was watching and your and your
show is you got to be able to listen to
what you're told and react from it
someone like Rodney Dangerfield my
opinion would be able to pick up on that
rhythm cuz it's hot and fast and then
dovetailing off that for a second what's
the key to opening up sort of an awkward
chef for an awkward restaurant owner
before the cameras start rolling serve
them mediocre wings from a pizza joint
down the street it was purchased by the
camera guy three hours ago and sit him
in a room and tell them they can't wear
black I don't know I mean just make him
feel welcome so I want to talk to you
about your Bay Area sports affiliations
for a second I know that your greater
nation to the core but I want to talk to
you about the Golden State Warriors for
a second had my hat on this morning and
this might blow some people's minds but
is it true that you played a small
behind-the-scenes and help bring in
Kevin Durant over to the tie don't know
about that I don't know about that I do
know that were huge kt fans when this
got ready to happen and we were talking
about it anew his contract was coming up
but I know Katie's manager and I know
Katie I just kind of do a little text
out saying hey you know this would be
awesome I mean never in a million years
that I think this would ever take place
and the energy between that team the way
is and with Katy's performances his
abilities and all these it's just the
perfect fit
it ends up hitting someone starts
quoting that I was involved in it and I
think there was a tweet that was sent
out from the Warriors something along
the thing that I'm the secret weapon so
we'll see we went when we win this year
we'll see if I get a ring I've met Steph
quite a few times you know cuz like I
said now the food network thing is doing
great in the food no she's been a judge
for me on guy's grocery games and at the
greatest Steph story in the world
Steph came to watch our show when she
was on guy's grocery games her first
time and sitting right next to him is
writer maybe somebody pulled their kid
out of school to come down and sit next
to Steph Curry I don't know who would
have done something that ridiculous
so he sat there and as we go to
commercial break I keep looking over and
riders now sitting next to them and
they're comparing things on the phone
and it isn't about Feb it did but but
but did development like this and Steph
walks up to me at the end of the day at
the end of the shoot and goes hey what's
your address I said why would something
this time send the kids some shoes what
Steph didn't know is that I had been
working the back channels with Under
Armour tried to get shoes for Ryder for
Christmas I mean been working it trying
to get these shoes before Christmas Day
letters you show up from stuff I was
gonna ask if we could just start hot but
that's a mistake we've had one gets do
that
so Eddie Wong did he died pretty close
so we had your buddy Rachael Ray on the
show and she gave me she's the [ __ ]
phrase pointers but you're the king of
the catchphrase so much so in fact
you've almost developed a sort of
restaurant language so what I want to do
is bounce some of the most quotable
head-scratching petty isms off you and
you can tell me what the hell they mean
or where the hell they came from and
kind of give the backstory sound good
I think people pick up on it more than I
mean to say it cuz I don't really listen
to what I say it's like flavortown
people come up bring these you like
flavortown man I'm the mayor of
flavortown I'm like okay wow I didn't
even get it at first you know I was
hearing it and then Chico one of our
cameras our mainsheet camera guy on
Triple D says flavortown you said it in
the show I said oh really
oh okay put it on a flip flop put on a
flip flop I was trying what I was trying
to do is paint the picture that
this is so phenomenal the thing that I'm
eating that I could put it on this
napkin and eat it on that put it on
napkin Anita design you know something
very funny but what would be the worst
thing you can put it on and put on your
shoe what happened to be wearing a
flip-flop that day so I put on flip-flop
but eat it
the festival of pomp but when you ever
been on stage next to the stage and you
watch a group of musicians just tearing
it up and it's got funk and it's got Jam
and it's got attitudes got energy it's
got you know all those pieces
well when that's combined on a plate
that's a festival of funk
how did you pick the sausage so we tried
to make it kind of like a symphony you
know what I mean so like you know how
peppers usually it's the hollow funk
it's a total festival of funk hear the
hierarchy of heat that oh man
guy come on why I'm running on that bike
and ride it so you're one of the few
food personalities that not only has
this TV fame but you also have this
ubiquitous internet fame you know I'm
sure that you have some fans that know
you from guy's grocery games but then
there's a whole younger set that knows
you as this sort of fabled Twitter
legend are you aware of your sort of
position in this space as this meme God
do your kids ever show you it's the
weirdest thing in the world it really
cracks me up my son Hunter is 20 almost
21 he'll set him to me instead the good
ones I said come on kid dad don't waste
my time
she the porcupine won you a little baby
porcupine that's not your favorite it's
just sure there's the Angels
there's the Pablo Escobar let me ask you
about one thing because it's kind of
this fabled vine where you're signing a
Lean Cuisine and then you're tossing it
out to the crowd we remember that
believe that's true video I don't
believe so I don't I don't know I know
the event yeah I'd I know the event cuz
we were doing an event from Miller Lite
and Michigan and it was at the end of
this crazy cooking competition I don't
know exactly how the cooking competition
was put together and I remember walking
over the producer of the competition I
said or anybody are these folks going in
they know they just came down for this
event and I said what do you do with all
this food I mean you got there was
thousands of dollars worth of food there
i if you've seen the video I haven't
seen the video so I've heard the
question I've had people ask me if they
could send me the Lean Cuisine and if I
would sign it all I remember is I signed
a couple fat hams
you know I signed some bottles of Mario
Batali tomato sauce you know we were
giving out all kinds of stuff
[Music]
I mean do you want to promote it
properly I mean do we Vanna White that
or anything that huh what do you think
you know you can't use that cuz I'm
signed up that's that's awesome this is
like so packaging okay that's good
that's important to me the packaging
nice I think you could give it a little
pop yeah oh you'd you'd give that you
could light that rooster up yeah you
know what though on the printing though
it's a little a little I you know we're
small budget over here guy I yeah
sorry ever recurring segment on our show
called explain that Graham of what we do
is we do a deep dive on our guests
Instagram --fill interesting pictures
that need more context and with Guy
Fieri we have a theme it's guy with
rappers so I'll show you pictures of guy
petty with rappers and you can tell me
the bigger story sound good
you know these goodies these are the
best that's my brother that dude snoops
your brother's newb is the best you want
to talk about legit street cred with
your kid so we were at Coachella
two years ago it walked into snoops
trailer and walking snoop got em and you
know it's tons of people inside trail
and he stops everything he's doing and
he goes well man guy and I'm like and
Hunter standing right by me and Hunter
hadn't met him before hundreds just face
it and I'm like you know it was just a
little father cuz we just I don't I have
a pretty good little rivalry going gotta
let him know something I just had to
make sure he was ready represented guy
in Action Bronson Bronson's the best man
before I met him people said hey there's
this guy he's doing this thing and you
know it's kind of like about what you're
doing and it could be taken like he's
either giving you a hard time or he's a
fan or he's both or whatever and I'm
like okay let me see it I'm like I love
this guy
guys it's careful I told him I said
maybe when I retire
you know trim it up a little bit throw
bleach on it would get you again I'll
kick down the shirts I have one more for
you because you got a shout out in that
Drake song six man I mean I get the
story that I'll tell you about me and
Drake is probably one of the most
grounding things ever I mean this is
2:00 in the morning I got I was there in
Toronto shooting Triple D he's sitting
there just having dinner
in a dining room at the building that he
lived in his security we're big fans of
Triple D and so we just sat there just
gonna have this thing and I was telling
about my nephew I lost my sister to
cancer six years ago and my nephew is a
huge Drake and so I'm telling Drake just
about this story and he's listening and
he's listening and he goes hang on a
second when he leaves and I know where
he goes and he comes back and he brings
me down some Drake swag and a sweatshirt
and a couple t-shirts up because I want
you to give this to Jules well now what
do I do
I said you know you just gave me this
phenomenal gift for my nephew which I
gave to him you know when I got home and
Jules lost it you know I mean this
sweatshirt was like five times too big
for me doesn't matter kid we've rollin
that his roll metric sweatshirt you know
with the with the logo on the front but
so we started talking he said he said I
love food now look I don't cook I said
let's do it I said well let's get in the
kitchen what's maybe 1:00 2:00 in the
morning and the guys are just finishing
up from service and the chef comes
houses you do want to cook in my kitchen
we say well let's go so they just gave
us full run of the kitchen got a chef
coats we got into it and I'm gonna tell
you something I understand
I mean Drake is beyond mega super
talented but as I gave him just simple
little things to do in the kitchen he
just never excited me to clean the
bottle let me sign this one yes that's
the cop yeah
what is this this is a ghost pepper and
blueberry sauce from bravado spice co
crab and ghost peppers you I think those
pepper gets a lot of play you know it's
so exciting that you're gonna have ghost
peppers I don't know so I want to talk
to you about wine for a second because
in addition to owning a vineyard I know
that you guys are you giving me a hard
time that I bring you a bottle yes is
that kind of what just one little Reed's
gonna go down to the club right now
let's talk about one if you're gonna
choose your own adventure okay and you
have a bottle Sammy Hagar's Wabo Cabo
and you have a bottle of the hunt and
rides old vine Zinfandel where is each
one of those going if you're a choose
your own adventure with the bottle when
it goes to that Cabo Wabo or - Sam you
speech bar um it's not small-batch
that's just made a couple bottles up but
it's with a lot of time and attention
and care so it's not a margarita it's a
little bit more of a classy hangout were
you enjoying it on the rocks a no salt
and lime and all that [ __ ] we love
wine in my house my parents love wine my
wife loves wine I love wine made wines
that we like to drink I will tell you
this you won't have just one bottle of
hot rods in it'll be two and it'll be
friends and it'll be more friends and
friends don't leave when you start
opening wine like that friends don't
lean night carries that the night
carries on and the great thing is I
think great wine gives great stories and
as you can't tell I don't like to tell
stories
[Music]
okay now it's starting to warm up a bit
and mm-hmm
still I'm not bull I'm not bullshitting
you bro still your sauce is leading this
was not a deal I didn't even know he's
yours know if the assistant head or the
gentleman that brought us up from down
on the street which was Shady
yeah that's going on with that bro I
pull up in a car there's a dude standing
there with a hot ones t-shirt on and I'm
like are you the guy in is like yeah guy
and come on and walk upstairs and I ride
there and they're like this is this is
how it goes yeah yeah that's that's the
hot ones throw a respite experience
that's how we do it right there by the
guy with the shopping cart it was
awesome it was really awesome
so I have an unhealthy reliance on
carryout and as our fans know I have
zero kitchen skills but I would like to
get better so I'm hoping now I can
bounce some common bachelor lifestyle
cooking quandary is off you and you can
kind of give me sort of close this but
it is just we call this the penguin yeah
I have lots of different things the comb
I have the one-liners and then you have
I have like the hand moves and can you
put that to music break that down for me
just think there's retail whatever the
video there
[Music]
[Music]
okay can you give me an easy-to-make dip
that will impress at the Super Bowl
party queso dip good cheese dip if
you're gonna do a Super Bowl party
you're gonna make one item you're
bringing it over and you want to wow
your friends get some tortillas
350-degree oil fry your chips when they
come out hot hit them with a little salt
seasoned salt if you want you're good to
go we're gonna start off first with
sweating some peppers some jalapenos get
some poblanos in there you wanna get
some Anaheim we kind of mixed these
peppers in onions a little bit of garlic
then when that mixture is going then
water flour we're gonna take a little
bit flour a little bit of butter to make
a basic root and a little bit of milk
and really just kind of create a base to
melt that cheese in okay so now we've
got some peppers we got some onions
we've got some garlic got a little bit
of heat inside of this we're gonna add
that Roux that Roux starts to come
together we add a little bit of milk
building that bechamel now we start to
throw in the shredded cheese and always
shred the cheese yourself if you can I
mean by the shredded some we gotta put
something on the outside of it to keep
it from coagulating and it dries it out
of test so just get yourself a block of
nice cheesy like a nice sharp cheddar
something along those lines you shred
that cheese and just slowly drop at it
and kind of give that a little stir now
you could go anywhere you want with it
you can season it with a little cumin
you get a little paprika you get a
little Cayenne you get a little chili
powder and you can start to develop this
as that's starting to work over on the
side chop up some tomato roma some
cilantro a little bit of onion a little
bit of lemon juice make yourself a
little pico de gallo on the side a
little touch of jalapeno as well and
maybe you hit a little beer in there too
when you're when you're putting this
together just to it listen here's the
great thing about it as long as you make
your right and as long as you don't burn
it and as long as you don't have the
cheese too fast you got yourself a
pretty dynamite queso dip right there
and you can start fortifying you blow it
up with this stuff okay kicking it up a
little bit of sting in that so I want to
talk about your style for a second
because I know that you've taken
exception to people who think that this
is some TV lab situation bowling shirts
versa wyan shirts which direction do you
go or is it impossible to choose okay
let's get it straight
the bowling shirt thing I don't know
where it came from
I'm not a real big dress-up guy kind of
what she's what you get when we got the
pilot deal for Triple D let's start
let's still give me a little sting in
the back of the frame M Welsch I got the
pilot for Triple D they said bring a
collared shirt so I had a Dickies work
shirt we've had it was blue with a gray
panel in the front of it and that's what
I'd put on and whoever started doing the
Wardrobe started bringing those kind of
shirts around and that's what they
started putting on me and then this
whole bollinger the people are mailing
me bowling shirts with my face on them
and cars on them and my name and I'm
like where did this go you know and
people like you're not wearing the shirt
that I gave you I'm gonna wear those
shirts
this one is mad dog 357 okay it is our
second hottest hot sauce it's your
second hottest which cool walnut Mad Dog
kind of does a double entendre thing you
know have like the 357 like the gun sort
of preference with them in the 357,000
close all units awesome the little
eyeball swept on military so now that I
have the people's taste maker in front
of me I want to play a game of one gotta
go Viet e edition I'll give you three
options and you tell me which one you're
kicking to the curb does that sound good
okay burgers in and out Shake Shack
Steak and Shake you know respectively
they've all got their place Steak and
Shake all over the country more people
probably have that than they've had
either the other two Shake Shack an
institution in and out and institution I
def see steak chick vegetables kale
Swiss chard Brussels sprouts Swiss chard
is awesome and there's a lot you can do
with it but I'll kick it to the curb
pizza thin crust deep-dish our
Neapolitan Oh deep dish is gone and it
doesn't matter if I can even cross it
off I'm not I'm not into the deep dish
and that's that's bread with stuff on it
my favorite food city of Chicago I love
Chicago Chicago has got such a melting
pot such a melting pot of great food
without question some of the best but
the deep dish too spongy doughy yeah
appetizers nachos tots or queso dip come
on it's a tough one like who do you love
more Hunter Riley
we have one wing to go and one hot sauce
to go
this is Blair's Megadeath sauce with
liquid rage it's tradition around here
to put a little extra dab on the last
wing so yeah that will do you little
dab'll do ya little dab'll do ya you
don't have to if you don't want to know
you have a meeting after this oh this is
gonna be great everything you see there
experience this liquid rate liquid rage
okay all right that's generous that's
generous okay
yeah yeah I'm uh I'm hot out of reach to
rage killed it rage killed it she's a
gangster she's gangster sorry lady she
was like just doing them straight off of
a spoon and stuff she's crazy crazy oh
she didn't have good wings for her she
had like very high like she's like a
brine duh
like I don't yeah exactly and they
didn't I you got mine from down the
street it's it's not easy to get wings
in LA at 10:00 in the morning no cuz you
got in last night
no we did it we got it this morning
right only only the best four guys I got
looks Shady
that's hot mm-hmm yeah that's uh yeah
that's dumb that's yeah all right guys
we've talked about already there's a lot
to celebrate about guy but as we all
know heavy is the head that wears the
crown I do wonder while you're dying on
the Blair's Megadeth sauce with liquid
rage what do you say to the think piece
writers the culinary know-it-alls who
think that it's all bleached hair and no
sauce what do you say to the naysayers
out there guy feed you I really don't
give a [ __ ] I mean it's not that people
don't have their opinion I think
everybody should have their opinion but
I really don't get to tied up with it
if my mom walks up to me and says hey by
the way don't ever wear that shirt again
on the show all right no more sir I got
you if my manager Reid comes and says
hey by the way you shouldn't have said
that on that I'll listen to what he has
to say I mean have I ever been annoyed
by something without question I'm human
I'm just like anybody else but do I let
it get in the way of my day
well you don't let that get in the way
of your day and you don't let scorching
hot chicken wings get in the way of your
day either guy Viet E this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
I when I get a chance to be to have my
soapbox to stand on for a second
that's what I like to say this food
revolution that's happening right now
that we're all getting a chance to
participate in that you're doing a great
job of representing in a very sadistic
way teach your kids to cook teach them
how to cook we went through all these
generations of kids that we were in
processed foods and drive throughs and
all this you know nothing against
restaurants I'm in the restaurant
business but we need to have a time in a
place and we need to teach kids the core
fundamentals of cooking it's a life
skill put down the cellphone come in the
kitchen let's work together on cutting
the onion and making the queso dip right
now kids have got a tough situation so
teach your kids to cook
[Music]
it was great man you do a great job
you're very engaging by the way for the
record no water no milk whoa hey what's
going on hot ones fans if you like the
video maybe meet us halfway throw us a
subscribe if you didn't like the video
don't subscribe I don't want you I don't
want you in the tent but if you like the
video subscribe thank you very much I
appreciate you I love you more than a
friend